this morning our ongoing series issues
that matter takes up the immigration
debate that affects millions of people
in the u.s. a federal judge last night
blocked the Trump administration's plan
to phase out the daca program that
protected young people brought to the US
illegally as children earlier President
Trump negotiated with legislators from
both parties for nearly an hour with the
cameras rolling the president indicated
he's willing to reverse his position on
daca but also said he wants increased
border security measures in an exchange
with Democratic Senator Dianne Feinstein
the president suggested this could
happen in multiple stages that brought a
quick response from House Republican
leader Kevin McCarthy what about a clean
daca bill now and with a commitment that
we go in to a comprehensive immigration
reform procedure under daca and that we
can start immediately on the Phase two
which would be comprehensive I think
what senator Feinstein is asking here
when we talk about just daca we don't
want to be back here two years later
you'd have to have security as the
secretary would tell you I think that's
what you say without security what I
approve is going to be very much reliant
on what the people in this room come to
me with I have great confidence in the
people if they come to me with things
that I'm not in love with I'm gonna do
it because I respect them Republican
Senator James Lankford of Oklahoma was
in that meeting he is a member of the
Senate Homeland Security meeting senator
Lankford good morning good morning many
times when we talked to Senators we say
take us inside the room but we got to
see it all so my question for you though
is based on what we saw how likely do
you think a bipartisan deal on daca is
no I think it's been very likely all
along the president in September came
out and said I want to be able to have a
legislative solution for daca when I
also do border security do chain
migration and then he added later the
Visa Lottery when that becomes such a
big issue those four issues what he's
hammered on over and over again there's
been meetings in a bipartisan way for
about three months now to try to be able
to work through the process to be able
to figure out what that is
then you saw a much larger gathering of
yesterday at the White House I think
it's very likely but it sounded like
senator finds and I got the president to
sign off on a clean bill I you you would
have to be there for the whole context
the whole meeting the whole meeting was
all about two hours the press was in
there about the first 15 minutes of it
there was a lot of back-and-forth the
president laid out the very beginning
when he talks about doing daca it always
includes border security it always
includes chain migration those things
but he wants to limit it just to that
not do everything that was in the
comprehensive bill and then do a second
I think senator Feinstein misunderstood
that and she was trying to say well
let's just only do daca and he was
saying yeah that's what I'm talking
about knowing those four things that he
had already laid out as the principles
so at the end of this meeting senator
was there a net increase in clarity on
the president's position and on where
things are going or it seems kind of
mother you know I think there was real
clarity in it and he was trying to be
able to work through in fact at the very
end Kevin McCarthy came back again
cameras right at that point to be able
to go around the whole table with
20-some odd people there at the table
both House and Senate Republicans and
Democrats and say can we agree these are
the four areas we're not going to do
visa areas we're not going to do some
other areas that complicate a lot the
immigration conversation just deal with
the daca and trying to deal with a
permanent answer for what's happening
for those daca students then also deal
with border security we're still trying
to find out the parameters of what that
really means but I think there's wide
agreement on doing border security
obviously the Jay migration has been a
big issue if you have about a million
people I'd say 800,000 or whatever that
number may be for daca that's gonna
affect a lot of other families so we
have to deal with the chain migration as
well we'll figure out exactly what that
means for the future you say the border
security is still up in a debate isn't
that the key and important crux of the
issue which is Democrats don't want a
wall as a condition for taking care of
these daca kids it has been it's kind of
an interesting debate in 2006 that was
wide bipartisan support for what was
called the secure Fence Act at that time
650 miles of fencing was added to the
southern border that was not a partisan
issue at that point it has become a
partisan issue I think the president
tried to provide greater clarity
yesterday that I hadn't heard him say
before when he said out loud and for the
whole group with the media there I'm not
talking about a wall from sea to shining
sea this is not a 2,000 mile wall there
are certain sections of that border that
need a wall
then we need to do that other areas we
need technology other areas we need
additional manpower and quite frankly
there are loopholes in the law that
we've got to be able to fix that's part
of the border security if someone can
get across the border and use loopholes
in the law to be able to stay here that
becomes an issue as well so all of those
things are there but it's not a 2,000
mile wall I don't think that was ever
his intent but he was very clear about
it yesterday ok cuz he does seem to say
senator different things at different
times so you think doctors can pass yeah
you think without the border wall it's
not a matter of without the border wall
there will be sections of the border
wall that will be there that's that's a
part of border security it's just not
going to be a complete border wall for
the entire 2,000 miles okay it's gonna
be targeted specific areas do you think
it was helpful or hurtful to have the
cameras there it seemed to expose a lot
of contradiction and conflict within the
room you know I think it's entirely
appropriate to say the truth it was
interesting I don't know that I've not
been around this town very long but it
was interesting to be able have the
cameras in that meeting that long as
some of the press pool was leaving one
of the folks in the press pool turned
and looked at me and said that was
unprecedented we never had this kind of
access to a meeting in the White House
that we had yesterday because they were
in there for the majority of the meeting
but I think it is interesting for people
to be able to see the give-and-take
trying to provide clarity it's one of
the things I've said over and over again
about immigration
if you don't define the scope of what
you're talking about you'll never get on
to the next issue of trying to define
that and it's exceptionally important
for these daca students and for the
families around the country and quite
frankly for all of us dealing with
border security that we get this right
all right what was certainly interesting
to have a glimpse into the to be in the
room where it happened so to speak thank
you very much senator league for joining
us this morning good morning and welcome
John thank you sir
very nice thank you senator